so results from turkey's closely
contested presidential election again
down to the wire with a runoff looking
increasingly likely without counting in
its final stages president recep taip
erdogan and his main rival Kamal niklich
darolu remained short of the 50
threshold to avoid a second round so
let's take a closer look at the figures
as they stand right now with over
98.22 of the ballot to boxes opened a
president recep has 49.34 and his main
rival commodity has nearly 45 that is
according to State media President
erdogan says the opposition trying to
fool people by saying they're ahead but
stated if the election does go to a
second round he's ready for it
[Music]
we have seen that the margin with the
closest opponent is more than 2 million
votes and with the final result we will
see a wider margin we don't know if we
will have a runoff but if this is the
result of the first round the results of
the runoff will be the same if our
nation has decided to go to a second
round we will respect that decision
has been following the elections from
the headquarters of the governing act
party the justice and development party
in Ankara
we have seen that people have waited for
him for hours and hours of course they
were expecting him to say that we had we
had one they were expecting him to
declare and announce a victory but that
didn't come so he said that they're
clearly leaving the polls however they
have to wait for the unofficial results
to be announced by the high election uh
election election committee and he said
that we are not like the opposition we
are honest against our nation we are not
trying to manipulate the result while
the world are still being counted so he
says that the winner here in this
election is the democracy and he says
that the accusations that are coming
from the opposition toward the results
all the institutions are actually
showing the Eternal fights within the
opposition and that has been an argument
throughout of his whole election
campaign he was emphasizing the
fragility of the opposition and he was
saying that they do not have a common
wall but some interest and he was saying
that this Coalition will not be able to
to to to keep itself together then later
at the end of his speech he started to
talk about how they have distanced
themselves from the terrorism from the
peak okay because throughout his
election campaign he was accusing the
opposition also to cooperate with the
pickaxe as well so from that point on we
can see that it started to become a kind
of campaign speech so as of now it seems
that he's also expecting the elections
to go to the second round that's why he
has already started started the campaign
here
well turkey is opposition presidential
candidate
says he's ready for a runoff election
campaign against us erdogan hasn't
gotten the result he wanted we have to
wait for the final results if the first
round wasn't enough to receive the
Mandate we are going to get it in the
runoff election
who's at the CHP opposition headquarters
in Ankara
for the opposition Coalition the
preliminary results and the strong
indications that we are definitely going
to go to a second round
ah a Vindication for what they have been
saying over the past few months which is
the need for a new chapter in Turkey
they say that their rival president
of the ruling party failed to win a vote
of confidence and that the runoff is
going to be another decisive moment for
them to move forward and win the
election
their message has so far been that of
the need to restore democracy and to fix
the economy and it remains to be seen
that whether they will be able to
energize the voters across the country
to win the election
there is a new element in this election
which is basically the remarkable
performance of the third candidate
Alliance the opposition is going to talk
to him for a potential Coalition
expanding the Coalition for him to join
them if that happens their chances for
the winning the election are going to be
extremely strong but if they fail they
will have to look into biting into the
support base of presidential
in rural areas in across the country but
as far as the opposition is concerned
they say that the tonight is an
indication that the unlikely to reverse
the trend of the unprecedented number of
political election wins by President
and it's just a matter of time before
they defeat him in the runoff Ankara
a third presidential candidate sinan
Oran has secured over five percent of
the vote so far and if there's a runoff
his endorsement could be crucial and so
far he's refusing to bank either erdogan
or kalists
it seems the elections will go the
second round and Turkish nationalists
and kamales will be the determinants of
the runoff dear friends there'll be
another difficult 15 days ahead of us
and during this time if the elections
are completed with the current results
and go to the second round we will do
our best to make this process a good one
for our nation and our country at this
time we are not saying that we will
support one party or the other
who's in author who directs a Turkish
research program that Washington
Institute Think Tank he said the results
of Sunday's voter confounding
expectations
holes were showing that opposition
candidate kalistarolu would be in a more
more contested race with President
erdogan perhaps falling within the same
percent point so president erdogan
pulling up maybe three points ahead or
more uh that's surprising what is even
more surprising is the emergence of a
third pole candidate this was supposed
to be a two-way race between erdogan and
kalistarolu a third pole candidate his
name is Owen who got not a significant
part of the vote but enough to be a
spoiler he got five percent and that
probably denied either of the two
candidates at 50 percent outright
Victory are likely forcing the election
to a runoff this candidate on is an
anti-immigrant anti-uh Refugee candidate
and I think it's basically a new Epoch
in Turkish politics because both sides
will Court him to get his votes and they
will have to do at least something to
satisfy his base and his message
probably president erdon more likely
because on uh although his Centrist
supposedly doesn't uh sync up with
either of the parties polls were showing
that he was getting more voters from
erdogan's Alliance than from kalistaro's
Alliance and Owen has a bargain here he
wants the pro Kurdish hdp uh support for
the uh opposition leader Khali Charlotte
to end that will be a trade-off for the
opposition block whether they want
Kurdish votes or divorce of this
immigrant party so this has really gone
into into an interesting two-week period
in most countries elections last one day
in Turkey I think they'll last for 15
days starting from today until the end
of the runoff on the 28th
my colleague Sami zidane spoke with
political analysts hakan akbas and he
asked him whether the votes coming in
from abroad would help president erdogan
to cure victory
about 30 percent of them have been
counted and secondly
um there's already a 60 40 sort of
breakdown 16 in favor of erdogan but
most of the people who left turkey uh in
the last five years I would say they
would tend to vote for the opposition so
again it's unclear whether he would get
all the numbers and he needs to get at
least 1.6 million uh votes to be able to
emerge as the winners taking more than
50 percent of the votes but the task is
easier for him at this point given that
what we know he has he has 49 point
something percent
whereas
44 right he's closer he's closer uh to
win but uh it would appear that given uh
the breakdown of the overseas ballots
and uh most likely where they would be
headed as well as the Istanbul and
Country Istanbul votes or all contested
or objected Istanbul votes would most
likely favor the opposition because they
are the opposition strongholds so again
it is still unclear to me that anybody
would emerge as the winners